communication is one of the most
important feedback topics in consulting
if you work for one of the leading
consulting firms and you get a feedback
conversation with your manager it is
pretty much clear but how you
communicate will be one of the key
topics discussed in this conversation hi
guys my name is Heinrich and welcome to
my channel for learning thank you for
watching again communication something
that pretty much all consultancy is
cover in their onboarding training
programs young consultants need to take
dedicated communication classes and
communication is one of the things that
is discussed most frequently in feedback
conversations between young consultants
and managers when I was a young
consultant at McKinsey it was pretty
common that after I was on a call after
I participated in a client meeting and
maybe said something there I would get
some feedback from my project lead on
how I said certain things so of course
what you say is important this way and
if you said something that might not be
considered very intelligent or
appropriate to say then yes of course
this would be addressed in the feedback
sessions but at least as likely you will
get feedback on how you said certain
things so even though maybe what you
said from a Content perspective made
absolute sense the way how you phrased
it how you structured your message this
is something that as a young consultant
you will get tons of feedback in and
most of the knowledge strategy
consulting firms and the reason I
believe is quite obvious because in many
ways it is not always just about what
you say but also how you convey your
message to what extent you are able to
actually persuade the other person that
what you say is correct what extent you
have the other person to actually
remember the message points that you
have and then be able also to tell these
two or three key arguments to other
people in an organization in an
intuitive and persuading way
so what consultants is commonly do to
train that in your colleagues
in these training programs to the wrong
place and this wrong place frequently
goes something like this right you have
been asked to imagine yourself sitting
in the team room somewhere at the client
and now the client walks in and maybe
even a board member another senior
leader of the client organization goes
in and asks you hey Heinrich how is it
going what is the status right and often
you're taking a bit off guard maybe
you're in the middle of doing something
else and now the senior leader this
board member walks into your team room
and ask you to quickly and to-the-point
summarize what exactly you're doing and
what the status is and it's maybe you
can imagine this puts many people in
require a high amount of stress and many
people struggle to in a precise and
concise way and actually summarize the
key results of the project and give a
concise and professional answer to this
question of the board member in this
video I will bring up one of the points
that is really frequently addressed in
feedback sessions after these roleplay
situations and also in situations and
real projects where maybe indeed a
senior member of the client walks in and
you then as a young consultant say
something which may not have met the
standards of professional and concise
communication one of the key points that
is brought up in these kind of feedback
sessions is the distinction between
process and content when you communicate
when you answer such a question when
you're asked to give a status report or
ask to report on any project men or any
other business manner if you look at it
in a stylized way there are two ways how
you can talk about it it's either
focused on the process or it's focused
on the content and let me explain to you
what exactly I mean by that so let's
start with process what does it mean if
you talk process so let's imagine that
you've been working on a project that
has been about sizing market
opportunities in different countries so
your client or maybe your team need
asked you to analyze different
geographies and understand if there's a
country where it might make sense for
your company to enter the market with a
certain product that you as a company
are offering so if your communique
focuses a lot on process this means that
you focus a lot on the different steps
that you took to get to a certain
results you're talking all about what
you actually did in the last days in the
last weeks in the last months so an
example could be something like this to
say well I talked to the colleague in
the finance department and then I got
some numbers there and then I put some
market reports to actually combine the
data and then I also looked into
macroeconomic information about the
different countries and then I combined
these things but then I realized that
actually I'm missing certain information
so I went to the marketing department
head and then I talked to her to
understand her opinion about these
geographies and then again our compiled
it and then we had some alignment
meetings with other people of the
organization and then on looking at all
of this this is the result that we came
up with right so this is a process
oriented way of communicating and it
focuses a lot on the things that you did
in order to get through a certain reside
and many people like to talk about the
process this is something that many
people somehow naturally tend to to talk
about the process and probably due to
the fact that it really underlines what
all the effort is that you put into
something it underlines that you really
spend lots of time on a certain task it
underlines that you really worked a lot
that there were just many many things
that you did and you really made a big
and significant effort to solve this
problem but I hope that you also see the
downsides of talking about things in
this way because the focus is on the
steps that you took but the focus is not
on resides and I'll try to put yourself
into the shoes of a CEO of a large blue
chip company and you can assume that he
assumes that usually the people he works
with our professionals and that they
will make sure that the things they
present to him meet a certain level of
quality and
analytical rigor and the truth is to see
or such a company just will not care
about all the meetings that you had all
the time that you put into something all
the analysis that you took and they
maybe found although this actually
didn't work so that then you needed to
look it to something else and this that
maybe worked or not
the CEO will not care okay it does not
care about all the sweat or the work all
of the hours you put into something what
he cares about is the recite and if you
talk so much about the process you will
just waste this time and this is
something you should be very cautious
about to not erase the time of your
co-workers especially or if your parade
in such a professional environment so
this is now the process oriented way of
talking about something let's now look
into the content oriented way how would
you phrase an answer to the question
what you did on a project in a way that
actually focuses much more on the
content but not so much on the process
and talking about content basically
means talking about the results so let
me give you an example what would that
mean to talk about results so if you
talk about the content you could tell
your CEO or something like so from the
analysis that we did so far we conclude
that France like this the country where
for us it would make more sense to enter
with this new product that we have and
for three reasons first consumer
research shows that this product really
meets the needs of French consumers in a
way that it is not the same with the
consumer behavior patterns that we see
in other countries the second reason is
that the competitive situation in these
countries is that currently there is no
strong competitor there offering a
similar product so if we go there now we
have an advantage because we are the
first we can now quickly grow in market
share before maybe others then join the
market later the third reason is that
our operations are very well set up to
enter the French market because we have
warehouses we have a supply chain setup
that is very effective in serving the
French market at the moment it is much
better suited for the French market then
compared to other markets which you
might be so
instead so now let's make a cut to you
this is just an example of how you could
phrase such that no much more focuses on
the content of course not the arguments
that I said we're a habit rarely and
depend on the specific situation that
you're in but hope that you see the
difference that what I did not do is
explaining what all the steps were what
all the data is that I analyzed what the
meetings were that I had what maybe
first I thought but then I needed to
revise because I found out that it
doesn't make sense and something entity
makes much more sense all of the things
I did not talk about what I did talk
about is what the reside us and what the
key arguments are that actually back up
this recite now ask yourself what would
be beyond so that the CEO likely would
be much more interested in and for my
experience in working for several years
of consulting I can tell you that
letters the proper answer to given these
situations letter answer is an answer
that somebody communicates
professionally and effectively we give
so talking about the content is really
the way to go I cannot stress this
enough communications so crucial in any
professional environment and focusing on
content instead of process we're talking
about things that you did when giving
status updates we're talking about your
projects we're talking about the things
that you're working on is really crucial
and distinguishes you as a professional
communicator and of course now I talked
a lot about consulting examples I talked
a lot about the consulting context but
the truth is that this type of
communication behavior is relevant to
pretty much any job that you have it
really does not depend at all in which
industry you're in making sure that you
focus on professional communication is
absolutely key what you'll notice even
when you work in large bhutesu companies
that a lot of people really struggle
with good and effective communication
even senior leaders of some of these
companies really struggle with effective
communication this is something where
you can actually improve very quickly
and make a difference and just shine in
contrast to all these other people and
the key phrase that just summarizes this
kind of communication patterns if you're
looking for a name for all of this to do
further research
it's called top-down communique
she top-down communications the holy
grail in professional communication and
what I just talked about the distinction
between process and content it's just
one aspect of it there are many other
aspects in top-down communication so I'd
like to hear from you I'm interested to
learn more about what professional
communications are about let me know and
I might cover other aspects of this type
of communication in future videos just
as the quick tip if you just want to get
started right away the Bible of this
top-down communication approach is a
book that is called the pyramid
principle by Barbara Minto
it's a book that at least at McKinsey
almost every consultant reads and some
training programs you even get it as a
gift or something you're supposed to
read a lot or advance and I can highly
communicate this book I will even link
to this book in the description below so
if you're interested just check it out
so let me know if you would like to see
more videos on effective communication
in this channel so if you took any value
out of this video at all please press
the like button and subscribe and also
press the notification there to keep up
to date with my channels content I will
release at least one video every week
often even to videos so subscribe to
stay posted I will bring you lots of
content on how to be successful in the
first years in your career drawn from my
experience at McKinsey they're not also
working in a senior leadership position
in a German retailer let me know if you
have any questions in the comments I
will do my very best to give an answer
to every single comment that you write
so hope you're all doing well and had a
good time
stay safe keep learning and thank you
for watching this is highly for firm
learning